really and let's talk about what's cool
at school when the 6th 7th and 8th
graders at o'callaghan Middle School
tell you this isn't your dad's middle
school they're not kidding
you know there's something extra going
on there when you find out the school's
got another name for itself the I3 Learn
Academy Innovative interactive and
individualized
they're especially proud of the robotics
program where over their three years at
the school students learned the pieces
parts that go into robots how to design
and build a working machine and the
coding to put it all in motion
and they're hosting four robotics
competitions this year while staying
focused on their goal of getting to the
world championship in Dallas next May
as if that's not enough they also teach
web design video production video game
technology my question is do they hire
out
we always want to know what's cool at
school you got something let us know
cool at school under the Community tab
at 8newsnow.com or just email us cool at
school at 8newsnow.com I mean you talk
about sixth seventh and eighth graders
doing stuff that you and I never even
heard of and they're just having fun
with it yeah well and some of it may
really stick with these kids absolutely
that may be their career path yes as
they go on what I remember about school
was the greatest Technologies when I
first got my hands on a mechanical
pencil and here they are designing
robots seriously you know what I mean
like it's it's crazy what they can do in
school so congrats to the kids at
o'callaghan Middle School
a mechanical pencil yeah you know you
had a little button on it on the top
yeah I think they still make them
there's a Christmas present for John
Legend